[Music]
are we ready to go we're good
good you're saying my friend it's good
to see you really good to see you super
nice to be back in the inner sanctum the
sanctuary this is my third podcast in
this room I know that you begin to be
irregular I know I'm just gonna I should
just call you up when I'm on this side
of town or apart I need somebody I need
someplace to do if I did okay we got it
well the energy is so good in here and
originally we had talked about you
coming out to the house but the studio
space that I have still isn't quite
right and when I started to think about
it I realized like well this is an
amazing place to do this like what am i
what am i fighting here oh yeah this is
like a man cave of light yes a very
specific type of man cave populated with
lots of spiritual artifacts and many
many frogs
yeah frogs are you know frogs are what
we all are were that we're born as one
thing and then we evolved into who we
are you know we're born is what we are
and we evolved into who we are and
that's what a frog is it's born as a
fish and it then involves into a an
amphibian mm-hmm that's able to breathe
air yeah
well I'm part in phibian so I relate to
that I saw those photos fan if you had
to run across an island then jump in the
water and swim to the next Island and
then yeah it was a crazy race in cold
water and with your shoes on with your
shoes on the whole time all day long ten
hours and cific and yeah yeah and so
then running in wet shoes is kind of
blister territory isn't it it is I was
lucky I didn't get any blisters but my
shoes filled up with like sand and
little pebbles and things like that and
you're kind of running on that you just
have to get comfortable with that
discomfort because you could stop and
empty them but they're just gonna fill
up again the next time you jump in the
water and run up you know the beach it's
like her cell it was an experience for
sure yeah it was cool and you guys did
it in what how many hours
10 hours and 40 some-odd minutes and how
many of those how much of that time were
you actually in the cold water and what
was the temperature of the water that
was my biggest fear was how cold the
water was going to be because all you
need is one cold front one storm to blow
in because you're so close to the Arctic
Circle and it can completely change
everything but the water ended up being
like I don't know 56 or something
somewhere around there so it was cold
but not bone-chilling ly cold so you
know you're in and out enough and then
you're running and you're warming up and
just when you warm up you jump back in
the water again
but actually on the longer runs that
felt good to jump in the cold water
so the temperature wasn't the limiting
factor that the the most difficult part
for me was just the technical terrain of
the land because it was so rocky and
slippery I mean you're on all fours
climbing up these granite slabs and and
kind of trudging through marshes where
the water is almost up to your knees and
you know it was more like The Amazing
Race or something like that like then it
was running it wasn't actual there
wasn't that much actual running like a
lot of it was bushwhacking and that
really took its toll you know of course
you know this really well that you spend
three minutes or more in water under
sixty degrees and you reset your
metabolism you reset your glands and
organs it's really really healthy yeah
have you followed the work of wim HOF
yeah yes yeah the Iceman yeah so I had
him on the podcast talking all about
that kind of stuff man
yes he's totally devoted yeah well he's
I mean at his core he's he's an ancient
yogi that guy and he studied the
practices of pranayama I mean its with
him what's interesting is it's much more
about breath work than it is about the
cold the cold is what gets a lot of
attention even all the kind of stunts
that he does and and what he can do in
cold water is amazing but the breath
work is really rooted in the ancient
traditions of the Yogi's he's found a
vernacular to talk about it and teach it
in a modern context where people can
actually hear what he's saying
he's had a huge impact and he's cool
he's got great energy I mean he's
Anatole I totally the Yogi's of the
South Asian subcontinent in the south
we're doing hot yoga year-round right
because southern India is hot all the
time
and so they were doing what would be in
the modern-day vernacular would be hot
yoga and the the Yogi's that were in the
Himalayas in the Himalayas you know they
were doing it on snow sometimes right
they would even have moments when they
would sit and melt snow with their body
and so yeah cold water is a big part
even a big part of our lives because we
do cold shower every morning to flush
what happens is cold water you know the
largest organ on your body is your skin
mm-hmm
and so when you get in cold water it
contracts all the capillaries in your
skin
forcing massive amounts of blood inside
the body if you leave it in there for
three minutes that has completely
flushed your glands and organs and now
you're ready to go yeah literally ready
to go yeah well anybody who doesn't
knows you have this amazing you know
rejuvenating feeling after you've
experienced that yeah and yet you know
it's still so hard to do what doesn't
there's an old saying that no matter how
long you wait the cold water never warms
up it's it's that thing of playing in
your head you know I was like waiting
around for jumping in mm-hmm
doing the plunge well you hear all these
stories you know I don't know what's
real and what's apocryphal about the
ancient Yogi's going into the caves and
not eating for you know however you know
extraordinary periods of time and and
just going into these you know breathitt
Aryan fugue states or you know eons on
end and yet the Iceman you know wim is
really kind of doing this in front of
cameras and with doctors and you know he
injected himself with some kind of
endotoxin and it had no effect on him
and
so it's cool that he's able to kind of
carry that practice forward in a way
that is visible for a mainstream
audience and you know that you and I and
others including him and many others
your wife my wife etc are all you know
reincarnation from ancient Yogi's anyway
so you know we're just here from the
future trying to get this planet
up-to-date yeah
and I'm learning a few lessons along the
way I know
imperfectly let me just ask you one
specific question about that race what
what did you start running or swimming
the first leg was like a kilometer run
okay and then and then a long swim and
then a bunch of short little swims and
runs hmm and then it kind of opens up
later in the race there's a longer swim
and the 13 mile run like late in the
race but a lot of a lot of in and out um
yeah what was the longest swim one point
four kilometers I think yeah so all told
it was about six miles of swimming and
forty miles of running 75 oh that's a
lot of time spent in 56 degree water
yeah that was exuberant
trust me I was tired when I was done but
you know the Northern Europeans these
guys are Vikings and you should see how
they dance on these slippery rocks I was
falling all over the place and landing
on my butt and cursing and you know all
of that and these guys are just dancing
on these rocks like you know with
incredible grace though I have a earning
curve if I decide to go back to that
race I have plenty plenty to plenty to
go back to the drawing board on to
improve do they do it yearly yeah I mean
the guys that won our Swedish Armed
Forces guys and from what I can tell a
big part of their job is training for
this race their training on the course
they know exactly what rock you know to
climb out on and you know they know it
like the back of their hand so and it's
a calden advantage yeah a little bit but
you know it's a it's a really cool
subculture and the race directors have
injected this event and this sport which
has grown
with a really beautiful ethos of
preservation and sustainability like
they have or they have like a no litter
policy if you drop you know any kind of
like a gel or anything like that on the
course and you get caught doing it
you're just qualified like it's all
about respecting the the beauty of this
incredibly challenging and natural
terrain hmm so it's cool are the islands
inhabited they are but the population is
very low and during the winter months
like almost no one's out there like the
island that we finished on I think it
has a population of 40 or something like
that you know in their tiny little
islands so there's little cabins there
and people have small farms and and I
think it's like a very insulated
community where people are living really
simple lives and there's something
really amazing about that yeah and you
know that it was that part of the world
and a bit further south that created the
lifestyle that neither you nor I have
any part of it being vegan but when you
know the early migrations of pre humans
and humans were adventuring through the
the lands of what's now Europe and and
Russia and have you and the Ice Ages
struck food was destroyed and humans who
are biologically plant-based beings
right all of a sudden had to eat all
these flesh foods so those are the areas
they're really pristine they're really
beautiful but if we were to be in a
sustainable situation year around it
probably wouldn't work out you know
humans are incredibly adaptable though
you know we're we we know how to survive
there's plenty of things that we can eat
to make it work but one thing I took
away from that experience was noticing
the happiness quotient in that part of
the world and people who are living
these simple lives are incredibly
fulfilled and
content and in contrast to you know Los
Angeles or the way that we live like do
live amazingly sustainable by comparison
and that's something that you know I
wanted to get into with you
you know we've moved so far away from
that biological imperative of living you
know communally and connected with our
neighbors and you know as you wrote
recently in one of your morning prayers
we're at what 7.3 billion people on the
texas seven point five point five now it
changed that much since our last checked
it goes so quickly yeah and quickly
approaching ten billion and with that
we've been very good at creating
physical infrastructure to support us
through factory farms and super highways
and mega cities and the like but where
we have not been so good at maturing our
emotional infrastructure can you imagine
can you imagine a child in kindergarten
first grade having a course in Courage
having a course in confidence and then
you know going out through second third
fourth grade with those kinds of courses
how about a course in mid-teens of
dispute reconciliation mm-hmm
I mean and actually have those courses
equally as important as science math and
all of the other things which are giving
us our advanced technologies and
cultures you know but we've advanced to
such a degree in all those levels that
you spoke of but our emotional body is
still very primitive we're still
reacting to each other and we still feel
a threat in the difference that we
perceive look at how many people across
the world still actually believe that
the paint job on our body
means something right the color of our
skin and how many people feel that their
that their lives and their lifestyles
are threatened by the difference of
someone else's lifestyle and these are
just emotional opportunities for us to
really enable that which you said was
ten billion people on this planet you
know to live in harmony because if we
have problems with the numbers that we
have today we're not going to get
anywhere close to ten million before we
pull the plug on it yeah it is
optimistic as I am by nature there's a
bleakness this veneer of bleakness that
kind of covers everything and definitely
infuses my perspective of it and
informed by you know the unbelievably
divisive society that we find ourselves
in right now you know it seems as if we
should have matured past our differences
over our paint jobs and yet that seems
to be coming up as you know one of the
biggest issues once again like how can
we not have overcome this by this point
well I look at it as the people like us
you and I and our families and our
circles are the ones that are in need of
showing up and to me this world is like
a one-room schoolhouse or as I've now
started to call it a one-room daycare
center I think you know I've downsized
the I've downsized the metaphor door
downgraded the metaphor if we are that
one-room schoolhouse
we look across the planet and we see
people that are all seemingly physical
adults and many of whom are emotionally
not mature the consideration of skin
color sexual orientation gender etc is
all just an immaturity of the emotional
body
when we find that being a fabric of
judgment and when you have that what
you're looking at is okay everybody is
showing up but it's kind of like Lord of
the Flies where it's all haphazard and
people like us need to turn it into a
more appropriate setting you know in a
gentle way
I look at it is that we've got about you
know 3035 years before the bell curve
starts to slide down the the backside
and in those 30 to 35 years we will need
to you know that gives us enough time
but we will need to multiply ourselves
not in reproduction but in in actual
information dissemination where people
are understanding that it's their
fulfillment that gives us a sense of
that gives them a sense of being able to
sit in the presence of something that is
completely different than they are and
not feel threatened when you have
Chinese call it Chi in in yoga we call
it prana in English it's called
lifeforce you have it all the time when
you have that sensation that you have at
the end of a race not that you're
completely exhausted from but that
you're really exhilarated from that is a
life force that is moving in you and
that is really fulfilling you and when
you walk in that state of grace and any
of these differentials different
differentiating factors are in front of
you you see them as all similars all
similarities and that's what we need to
teach people to do is how to not just
pacify themselves with food not just
pacify themselves with comfort but to
really activate you know right down to
the cellular structure and open up their
their mental capacities so that this
emotional body can fulfill itself in a
presence that is so profound that no
amount of difference is a
differentiation but we're in a zero-sum
game
you know that's the game most people are
playing like there's only so much going
around and now this sense of lack and
urgency seems to be heightened right so
if you have then I have not or your
threat to what I potentially can have or
he has more I want what he has
so there's a lot of a lot of mental
barriers that we have to overcome to
reframe the paradigm about how we're
sort of living our lives on a daily
basis right I mean we're being stoked by
fear everywhere we turn even the
billboards when we drive down the
streets here the messaging is diffuse
and everywhere and it becomes almost
impossible to kind of escape the the
clutches of the culture that wants to
hold us in this place of being afraid of
judging ourselves by what we have and
not and don't have in comparison to our
neighbors and I think this is you know
wedging this divide that is being you
know stoked by our governments and
people who are lining up on both sides
to fight this battle that is just
pushing us further and further apart
from the solution there's a great study
and a and a series of books
it's called M brain and the M stands for
multi there's and doctors are talking
about the brain in your gut and they
have neurology in the heart and they're
talking about the brain in your heart
and then there's the brain in your head
well the brain in your gut is what
connects it either connects you with
nourishment it's how you digest food the
brain in the heart has a unique quality
because it it actually encompasses both
the heart and the lungs and both the
heart and the lungs exert to give and
then have to completely relax to receive
the brain in the head is all we educate
and the brain in the head is analysis
differentiation is very two-dimensional
it's very right wrong good bad yes No
so if all I'm doing is walking around
with the brain in my head educated and
I'm a bit ignoring all the other brains
then I am unfulfilled and I am seeing
that what you have I want I am seeing
that you having it means that I can't
have it and there's a limited zero sum
factor involved but if I'm connected
with my gut if you and I are connecting
at the gut level which is where you get
your gut you know sensation then what
you have I have and your happiness is
actually my happiness think about the
heart brain which is one of the most
interesting factors and that is that in
order to receive I have to completely
relax most people are in this world and
they're getting in other words they're
striving to get striving to get striving
to get well if you're always in that
hyper tense striving to get you never
receive and so if I never receive what
I've gotten that I'm always going to
need to get more and this is where greed
comes from this is where overconsumption
comes from this is why we're deforesting
the entire planet I like that analogy of
the heart and the lungs because that's
that's true the exertion is in the
giving like if you're by extension in a
place of using your your your willpower
your energy your chi or prana you my
force and channeling that into providing
for others giving of yourself then when
you relax that's when it comes back to
you your lungs are naturally open a
collapsed lung is a big serious event
but when you're running your effort and
breathing is on the exhale mm-hmm and
your inhale it actually happens
naturally and the same thing happens in
your heart the effort is in the pumping
the blood into the body and then when it
completely relaxes that swell of blood
that's been pushed out into the body
comes rushing back into the heart I like
the idea of you know focusing on these
different brains the heart brain
acacia brain but our education system is
about the head brain head brain oh
that's it and what I've experienced and
what I've seen other people experience
is when you lead your life by by your
head brain and you're ignoring the other
brains you end up with some form of
disease either mental emotional or
physical think about the kids that are
no longer able to cope with school and
it's the numbers are rising and these
are the kids that go out into the world
and they have great relationships and
they have great this and great that they
innovate they're entrepreneurs I mean
look at the biggest corporate
corporations in the world right now are
all being CEO die college dropouts and
the bottom line here is is that kids
these days need that education on all
three brains in order for them to
experience fulfillment when we educate
the gut brain the gut brain is all about
connections so we would have courses in
school about connecting with each other
and what we would also do is we would
have collective testing in other words
we train kids throughout school to do
their work on their own to hide their
answers to do it privately don't share
anything and the moment they get out in
the world everything is about you the
need to share and the people that are
the most resistance to sharing are the
ones that isolate themselves they're the
ones that end up being emotionally
unstable and then you have things like
what's going on you know with mass
shootings and and all of this violence
that's being created these are people
with unfulfilled gut and unfulfilled
heart they may be able to analyze things
perfectly with their head but the other
parts of their being are just not in
functions or not in balance yeah I mean
I want to get into the mass shooting
thing but before we get into that like a
couple observations you know I think
that we have an education system that
has essentially remained unchanged since
the Victorian era totally predates the
or sort of you know the way we teach
kids now kind of came out of the
Industrial Revolution and it was
training young people to prepare
themselves for the job market at that
time and it's kind of stayed stuck in
that well you know they fight all
everything we've learned about
psychology and education and motivation
and all of these things like we have not
been able to evolve how we are raising
our children in the classroom and we pay
the teachers the least mm-hmm
so we get those who are not necessarily
striving to be extremely successful but
they say that if you took professionals
from 200 years ago including teachers
and dropped him in the world of today
like lawyers doctors engineers what have
you the only one that would recognize
their jobs the teacher because nothing's
changed in education but everything else
has so we're educating children for a
world that doesn't exist anymore
the world has definitely changed
dramatically and that's a huge that's a
huge problem and it is interesting that
so many innovators you know are people
that had the the audacity the gall to
step you know one step to the left or
three steps to the left and opt out of
that system which has allowed them to
you know think more freely and
unrestrained yeah Microsoft was started
by a dropout Apple was started by a
dropout you know all of these other
major corporations were started by
dropouts and the end result is is that
they figured something out that wasn't
going to be taught in that educational
system right my daughter's go to you
know a very progressive school that in
certain respects is innovating in
certain ways and trying different and
new things and yet the other day my
ten-year-old came home and said that
they ran a drill at her school where
they had to prepare for what would
happen if there was a mass shooting and
it just crushed me it just it broke my
heart that my ten-year-old daughter had
to think about that as a possibility and
prepare for it and put that into her
brain because all of a sudden fear
factor is going to be dominant mice our
son went to a school that you would take
everybody graduated with straight A's
and here's how they did it
it was not about testing was about
teaching so if you took a test first of
all you only took one course other than
English and PE PE was everyday physical
exercise was a mandatory event and you
took English and then you took one other
course with and you would finish a
course in a month or six weeks it was
because you were really focused on it
you take a test you get 60% on the test
well most people that would be a flunk
set aside the 60% you start studying the
40% take the test again
whatever you pass you set it aside take
the test again until you're down to what
you know every single piece on that
original test and not only that but you
were twinning you were twinning with
somebody else and being able to bounce
ideas off of them so that they were
training you to work together and to
never accept failure right cooperation
and teamwork that seems like a much
better way of doing it you know the idea
of depth over breadth but now it's just
we got us you know it's like a rock
skipping across the surface of water or
like they're moving so quickly through
so many subject matters so rapidly but
only dipping you know centimeter beneath
the surface on every single thing so
that you know the child takes the test
and they're on to the next thing and
they've forgotten what they you know did
like I don't remember anything that I
studied in high school I took AP
calculus I I don't know what calculus is
can you imagine if as a facet
professional from nine to ten you were
one career and from 10 to 11 you were a
different career and from 11 to 12 you
were another career and then you went to
lunch and then you did three different
careers after lunch not a good idea yeah
there's a school in Russia I forget what
it's called there was a documentary made
about it and I think it's called the
school if I could be wrong about that
but it's this experimental school where
all the kids irrespective of age and
grade are kind of cohabitating and and
in the same classroom where the younger
students are helped by the older
students and they do just that they pick
one subject and they go super deep into
it and they all cooperate
help each other until everybody's
mastered it and they don't move on until
they've kind of conquered that and then
they go on to the next thing so it's
very focused on one specific thing and
group effort
collective effort you know they say that
if you want to learn something read
about it or listen to it which is good
for these podcasts if you want to know
something write about it and if you want
to master something teach about it and
so a system such as that one you just
described would have all of those things
you would have it would have reading
writing and teaching because the Younger
would teach the older the older would
teach the younger and the mastery would
be phenomenal let's get back to the mass
shooting thing so there was this
shooting in Texas just the other day and
this is the second one and you know how
are the two weeks or a week and a half
or something like that the rapidity the
frequency of these tragic unbelievably
violent acts is accelerating and this is
unprecedented I think those were like
the last two or two of the most
devastating violence in the last 35 or
something like that what is happening in
our culture why is this going on and
what is the the malaise the sickness
that lies at the the core the locus of
what's going on in our culture that's
leading to this and why is it happening
now if you look around the world and you
you see industrialized and I use
quotations civilized nations the only
one that is having this kind that isn't
at war that there isn't an actual war
being fought on their soil so that takes
away Syria and Iraq and Afghanistan and
those places that are you know there's
serious combat taking place but you
think of the United States in Canada and
Mexico and Brazil and and Russia and UK
and France and Germany and all of the
other countries around the world there
is only one country in what
this is happening at this level and you
got to realize that America is more than
a nation is a commercial organization
and so Commerce will take precedence
over health with the only major nation
that has created an industry out of
healthcare in which there's profit in a
company when a person gets sick and so
that really changes the game we're the
only country that has this free form of
weapons that can just be sold in in
shows and unregulated circumstances and
somebody supposedly has a database that
checks background checks are run through
but then it was a UPS we forgot to
register this guy's violent nature with
the database and the oops is always on
the side of commerce because anytime
there's a mass shooting the sale of
weapons and the sale of bullets and the
sale of all of these things goes
skyrocketing and the stock prices of the
publicly traded weapons companies goes
skyrocketing and all of this incredible
capitalists and I'm not saying there's
something wrong with capitalism but
there's something wrong with having
capitalistic needs over human needs of
health and and actual safety so we have
a country that is focused on the
marketplace more so than any other
country on Earth
therefore it demonstrates its ability
you said something about the happiness
factor of the people where you were
running is much higher the happiness
factor in America is very very low
because we are focused on capital
markets
rather than collective health collective
well-being family unity etc yeah I think
that all of that is correct and right
and I would agree with that and I think
also you know beneath the surface of
that or as you dig deeper it is about
the disconnection you know this is this
is an illness not just of the human
beings that are perpetrating these acts
but an illness of our culture right it
is a dis ease that I think is being
driven by dissatisfaction and depression
and disconnection because of the way
that we lead our lives like if we were
living in a communal you know village
based society where there is
accountability and there's joint purpose
and there is a collective understanding
about how every in each and every person
is contributing then I don't think that
you see these things because even in
these war-torn parts of the world where
firearms are you know proliferate and
there's plenty of guns around they're
not going into their own communities and
and decimating people you know that's
just not happening so fundamentally the
individual who is the perpetrator of
these acts is almost in an agent or an
example of a larger malaise that I think
is is is a chronic condition of an
indicator of where we are at as a
culture if we were educating children as
an emotional creature as well as as a
mental creature we do a little bit of
physical education very little the diet
is terrible across the board but if we
were to check out the physical education
check out the emotional education as
much as we focus on the mental education
then what you're saying wouldn't be
taking place because connection would be
paramount my connection with my when my
friends would be graded as high as my
observation of
makes calculus like that you can't
remember calculus and yet you were an AP
calculus that means you were an Advanced
Placement calculus right you know I
can't remember things that I studied
either and most of those things were
crammed the night before because you
were having too much fun doing the other
things that should have been covered in
education to just spend all of your time
studying the idea that we could educate
children to be able to you know when
when the pressure builds up inside
because these guys are explosive and
that's why they're shooting the guy
that's shooting from Las Vegas he's
exploding that's why he's shooting it's
an expression of who he is if we could
create an opportunity so that we could
see the explosion beginning to rise in
each other and do the things that
comrades that that fellow human beings
do for each other
be like grazing animals rather than by
territorial carnivores and I take it
back to our diet again the only
creatures on the planet that are
territorial are carnivores they mark
their territory they protect their
territory herbivores share their
territory and they love it when they are
grazing together so taking it from the
physical level of diet moving that into
the emotional level because when you eat
blood food you become aggressive the
blood is forced between your teeth and
your gum and there's sensitive nerves in
there that when you get blood forced up
in there you feel like you're dominating
your environment and this is just
something we're not prepared for as
herbivores the human being is a plant
based biology and it is not prepared to
feast on blood it is not prepared to
have those kinds of aggressive attitudes
and then put that together with complete
lack of emotional education you have
this brilliant creature who's super
aggressive emotionally unstable and now
he can go to the corner store and buy a
gun this is an AB
saluté mess and nothing has it more
advanced than this country the u.s. oh
it's been completely systematized mmm
you know and it's it's a display of
utter desperation on these these people
who are in tremendous pain who feel like
they've been passed over and they're not
being heard and the only way to be heard
is to perpetrate an act so horrible and
the amount of pain that that person must
be carrying in order to do that and then
the way the media covers it just
perpetuates the cycle because it plants
the seed and the next person who's
coming down the assembly line who's
feeling the same way and sees that is
the only way to get some level of public
validation on the way out recognition
yeah it's great become a superstar on
the on the subject of taking in you know
eating animals and and and and what that
does to us spiritually and emotionally
you know Julie always says like if
you're eating the animal you're taking
that violence into your body there's no
way that that can't be impacting you on
not just a you know a cellular level but
an emotional unconscious level and I was
just at this conference in Austin the
other month it was like the conscious
capitalism conference and they're always
amazing CEOs there who are socially
minded who are trying to do good in the
world it was really inspiring and I met
this one guy this doctor dr. Zach Busch
who is an epidemiologist by trade and
he's done all these incredible studies
and I got into this this is a guy I've
got to get on the podcast he wasn't like
he was blowing my mind but he was
telling me about studies that he's
conducted in-depth detailed analysis of
what happens to you physiologically when
you eat meat and taking in like the you
know when they when they kill these
animals and they're terrified of course
when they're being killed
they're in a hyper this hyper acute
emotional state where the hormones are
raging and so that in turn when you take
that into your body or your teeth
those hormones and the only he's been
able to gauge like the impact of that on
your own and you're in your endocrine
system is human body and how that
translates into you know Aaron's
behavior
it was wild I mean he can say it much
more intelligently than I but it's
chemicals and those chemicals don't
don't die those chemicals aren't even
cooked out of the food so the you are
just saying the animal is in a
heightened state of terror heightened
state of Rage now you're eating terror
and rage and some protein and that's all
the meat is and we don't need to be
eating this because there is as you know
I mean we're obviously talking to the
audience here not to each other but if
the fact is is that when our bodies are
trained you can't do this overnight but
when your body is trained to break down
vegetable protein into its individual
aminos and then reassemble it into an
animal-based protein it's actually
working out it's like lifting weights
it's like your spleen is lifting weights
your your kidneys are lifting weights
your liver is lifting weights everything
is exercising when you just put in all
ready-made protein already produce
protein and with it you're putting in
those chemistry company components of
fear and rage and terror and betrayal
I mean we're raising these animals
they're like pets well they're pets in
captivity and a very cruel in the state
but they're being taken care of and then
all of a sudden we come in and we
slaughter them Yogi's throughout history
have said that killing an animal out of
necessity and killing it with respect
has a certain validity but raising an
animal and then slaughtering it has has
such an effect upon the human psyche
that it actually turns you into a
murderer even if you're not the one that
has been murdering all these animals
you're letting slaughterhouses do it
you're eating
the chemistry of murder so you're
becoming a murderer Mahatma Gandhi was
once in jail of many times he was in
jail and suddenly he started to have
these murderous thoughts and so he sat
with him in deep meditation and it came
to him that well perhaps there was
somebody that was involved with his food
that had some of these kinds of thoughts
and he found out that the guy that was
the main cook in the kitchen was in jail
for murder so all of these components
are very subtle you talked about the
doctor dr. Bush in at the conference the
endocrine system is a ductless system in
other words the transmission between the
endocrine glands is happening on a on an
electromagnetic basis as well as on a
chemical basis and so there's radio
waves going in our systems radio waves
going between our systems and if I'm
preparing food I've got radio waves from
my attitude going into the food in the
Buddhist tradition they always had the
highest monk being the cook and then
everybody was eating the highest food
that could be that could be prepared
yeah Julie always tells a funny story
about a yoga retreat that we went on
when we were when we had first met and
we would go to the center and it was
this place nearby and it would be all
vegan food and the food like looked
delicious but everybody got sick or
everybody just felt terrible after
eating this food and it turned out that
the person who was preparing this food
was just a very unhappy angry person and
so you know she she was in injecting the
meal with all of that angst and energy
it seems like oh yeah well this is a
crazy hippie idea or whatever by totally
rillette but I think that there's truth
in that and so Julie's always like you
know look you can prepare the most
beautiful plant-based meal but if you
don't prepare it with the right
mindfulness and spirit and approach then
you're missing the point and what was
great about dr. Bush is like look you're
you're your guru Singh you're your Sikh
yogi
no musician guy I I guess I'm a hippie I
don't know but like this Zach Busch guy
he's like legit not a hippie at all like
not a he's not a vegan activist or
anything like that like he's just like
this is what the science is showing me
yeah well that's what we're going to
need to convince the convinced able and
not everybody is convinced about you
know it's a one-room schoolhouse once
again and we go through many lifetimes
in many incarnations and some of those
incarnations are on this earth and some
of them are on other planets that are
like this earth and those of us that
have been into the future which means
we've come from planets that are ten
years a hundred years a thousand years
ten thousand a million years more
advanced than this one and we come back
to this planet we are actually from the
future and we're the ones that are
actually the ones that are responsible
for this one-room schoolhouse is one
room daycare center we're the ones that
need to show up I feel that we're the
ones that are responsible for the mess
because we're the ones that are
responsible for cleaning up the mess and
we're the ones that have to show up in
big numbers I mean big numbers in terms
of what it's possible is somewhere in
the neighborhood of you know 22 million
right now 22 23 million but with our
awareness we could shift this planet so
remarkably think about it the the iPhone
has now been around for 10 years and
everyone on the planet is totally screen
fixated think about what it would be
like if we were a hundred years in the
future and what we would have advanced
to we may have already gone through the
crises that we're going through here on
earth we might have already gone through
the collapse of society that we may be
experiencing in the near future on earth
and we've come out the other side so
we've lived on those planets we know the
secrets of how to get through it we've
been sent back to here in another
incarnation to kind of cross pollinate
that awareness now it's our job to
awaken that awareness inside of us and
we we do awaken it by going on crazy
the races in the Baltic Sea we do awaken
it by in deep meditation we do awaken it
by doing yoga we awaken it through all
these methods we're the ones that need
to show up because we have to then take
like an adult would in a in a daycare
centre when two kids are squabbling only
in this world they're squabbling with
weapons and throw our arms around both
of them and say okay we're gonna take a
timeout we're gonna go walk out in the
fields and however we end up doing that
we may not even know just like 50 years
ago a touch screen was unthought-of and
now a touch screen is in everyone's
pocket so the technology of how we will
emotionally take care of that move we
may not know yet but if we really force
ourselves into a corner we're going to
discover that means and that's what I'm
working for I'm working for discovering
the means of creating the impossible the
ability to go into really really high
tense situations and find peace in fine
calm and so how does one comport
themselves if we take a case study let's
take the shooting at the church the
other day right and given the fact that
we're all screen obsessed and everyone's
staring at their iPhone you know what I
spend a lot of time thinking about is
how do i leverage the platform that I
have and the audience that I have to
communicate in a way that can sort of
elevate the conversation and raise the
frequency beyond thoughts and prayers or
by taking aside and pushing back and
fighting and so what happens to me is I
don't really know how to navigate that
in the best way and so often I end up
remaining silent on issues that I have
an opinion on or perhaps I could provide
a perspective that would be helpful but
I'm not sure the best strategy for
approaching that
and being an age like sort of trying to
be that that that agent of positive
change well I think being silent is
sometimes very helpful because another
opinion isn't necessarily the answer and
so I am I'm with you on that I look at
it in these kinds of realistic terms and
some of it seems realistic to the
listener and some of it will seem a
little bit of a stretch but Abby is
leaving the hive and it's in need of a
flower and so it flies into the air and
it has there's pheromones in the air
there's fragrances in the air there's
colours in the air there's all of this
that are coming from around its
environment the environment can be a few
miles away but the bee is still
sensitive enough to be able to pick up
on those messages the fragrance messages
and the color messages and it follows
those tracks because the color from the
light that's coming from the flower is
in the air is is in the the track that
the bee is going to be following the
pheromones from the flower just like a
dog can smell a lot more than we can the
bee can smell so it follows those
pathways and it finds the flower what if
many of us were so aware so acute just
like the bee that we could smell an
unresolved violent temperament arising
in some location nearby and we would
then be attracted to that circumstance
which is in this case a person that is
starting to stockpile guns because
they're not resolving their angst
they're not resolving their anger and
their rage and their fear and their
separation within themselves and so all
of a sudden these millions of people I
call it millions of avatars millions of
messiahs throughout the planet and I'm
saying the next several decades are
going to be used to build that and that
we can actually sense who in our
community is is feeling this way
and we could go up to them and be an
answer there was a great story about a
school in the mid-south somewhere like
Tennessee Kentucky a few years back and
a lady was working the front desk and
this lady working the front desk
suddenly sees this guy with a couple of
weapons standing in front of her
and she went into a state of shock and a
state of shock is the literally you
out-of-body experience and the reason
they call it an out-of-body experience
is because you actually go into an
etheric consciousness you go into a
precursor of consciousness like a Precog
if from the movie Minority Report and
you all of a sudden you are in that that
precognition of realizing that there is
a condition that you're working with and
she said that when she started talking
she didn't know who was talking inside
of her but she started to communicate
words to the gunman that were very
soothing to him very understanding for
him and in about three to five minutes
the gunman was setting down the guns and
saying I want you to call the police
I've just about done something that I
would have terribly regretted so she
went into this altered state and
literally engulfed this person in what
love that we've never kind of
experienced and she brought him down she
brought him down from that heightened
state of anxiety that heightened state
of disconnection to where he just said
calling the authorities because I want
to be controlled now and this is what
I'm talking about that we would become
aware of where those situations are
happening they could be happening three
miles away but we would be called to it
we would then be able to be in that
state of really a state of a channeling
kind of bringing in the love bringing in
the understanding now the Buddha had a
great prayer
places I am to go I shall go people I'm
to meet I shall meet things I am to say
I shall say that which I am to achieve I
shall achieve and to be in that state of
just that pure channel of love being
able to assist somebody that as you've
said prior they're in desperate need the
perpetrator of these crimes is in
desperate need and if somebody could get
to them before they got to their act
that would be the state of grace and
that requires a level of connectivity I
think that were that we're lacking right
now you know I think Los Angeles is
perhaps the greatest example of you know
dispersed individuality because we're
all in our cars and we you know we it's
such a sprawling you know place where
it's very difficult to connect with
other people you know and to not know
what your neighbor is doing or even know
their names and and bridging that gap I
think requires not only you know going
back to what you said earlier about
really connecting with with that you
know that gut in that in that heart
brain in order to develop that awareness
because I think if you're if you're
really present with an individual and
you can get past your thinking brain and
you're just with them and you're looking
at them their eyes are telling you yeah
but everything is there like we were in
Julie and I were in Miami the other day
and we had a dinner with a bunch of
people and we sat next to this guy who's
sort of jokingly saying that that that
that that he could like you know read
minds or what he was empathic in a
certain way and he and he started to say
this is you know who you think you are
but this is what's really going on with
you and he and he's and he was very
accurate like and he did it with a
couple people but you know he was just
sort of being a Mentalist because he was
paying attention and I think we're all
wearing that on our face the signals are
there but instead we're gazing at our
phones and were in our cars and were you
know on Twitter or we're doing what
we're doing and that disconnection is
only widening rather than rather than
shortening every power that any human
being has ever had here on earth
is in every single one of us waiting to
be activated it's like you have almost
the identical genealogy that I do as the
identical genealogy is everybody does
we're like within micrometers of our DNA
and yet which one is activated in you
it's brown eyes and me it's blue eyes
etc which one is activated in our let's
call it super powers the super powers of
the Buddha the super powers of Lord
Krishna the super powers of Mohammed the
super powers of Jesus and super powers
of Zoroaster of all of these incredible
human beings that have walked the planet
at one time or another exist within
every one of us every one of those super
powers and therefore it's time not for
another great leader it's time for great
leadership and that means that all of us
who have an inclination to sort of
question the current way things are
going and not try to get on to it right
and get ahead of it but actually to get
under it and and and stand under it and
understand it and support it you could
develop I can develop all of these super
powers and I'm not talking about we need
to walk on water which would have been
very helpful in your race if I spent a
little more time with you yeah we got it
but what I'm talking about is the super
power of compassion the super power of
empathy that let me not necessarily read
your mind in a in a kind of in a small
way but let's let me read your being and
let me find out is there anything that I
can do for you being of service this is
what is going to have to take place on
earth it's time for a superhuman race
which is going to arise out of the
existing human race the kids that are
graduate students in the game of life in
the school of life are going to have to
rise
to the occasion and really set the pace
right now those of us that are in these
kinds of podcasts are you know thought
of us you called yourself a hippie or
they say woowoo you know and all of this
I don't think of any of this stuff as
woowoo I think of it as all just pure
science and technology well the science
is always present and all of your
lectures and sermons and in your daily
prayers like you're always talking about
physics and biochemistry and it's
interesting I think that's important
right like you're super into science I
am right there's one that's going to
come out as a matter of fact I was
working on it this morning so it's
coming out in a few days they have
discovered a crystal out in deep space
that's actually a quantum crystal it's
like so tiny it's not even nano you know
and Nana was six carbon atoms this thing
is below the atomic structure that
quantum crystals that do not apply
themselves to the Newton's third law of
motion which is for every action there's
an equal reaction and that which is in
motion tends to stay in motion this
thing the moment an action takes place
on it it multiplies the action you know
like in multiples of thousands and so an
action has a reaction of phenomenon this
is the exact same quantum crystal that
is in our spinal fluid and the fluid
around all of our ganglia our nerve
centers which is our brain our spine the
gut and the heart and this is that these
are those nano crystals through which
the light of consciousness shines and
literally when you have the awareness to
align all of this which is exactly what
happens when you're in the zone that you
get into when you're running when you've
passed through hitting the wall in a
marathon that sensation or remember
sleepy Floyd of the Golden State
Warriors mm-hmm and he like his average
points per night was this was like
decades it was a long time ago 13 points
a night was his average in one night he
hit 55 points and they said to him so
what happened he said I
No he said I'd dribble down the court
and the bat the basket was as wide as
the whole court no matter where I threw
it it went through and that's literally
being in the zone where the conditions
of your sensory system alter so that
they're in complete control of your
muscles
well you're transcending the thinking
mind exactly overcome that brain exactly
where time kind of fades away and space
gets distorted well yeah and it gets
distorted in the way of your intention
his intention was to make baskets our
intention is to you know calm people of
the hell well in a macro that is God
bleeped you can say whatever you want
there that's a podcast there's no
there's no network here there's no
middleman or intermediaries say whatever
you want I think that as trite as it
sounds in the most macro sense it is you
know look we've all been told this and
intellectually perhaps we understand it
that you know we walk around with
blinders thinking about ourselves we're
self-obsessed we're focused on me and my
path and what I'm trying to get and
achieve when in reality there is no
there is no disconnection between any of
us and we truly are one we're one living
breathing organism on this spinning
globe then spiraling through space as a
spaceship you know you know that's the
truth of the matter right and we have
such difficulty as human beings like
recognizing that fundamental aspect of
our shared destiny right and the more
that we can connect with that that gives
space to develop and breathe that level
of empathy with our with our fellow
humans but there's something about the
way that we're wired and perhaps it's
about the culture in which we're raised
where we not only forget about that
where it we we deny that very essential
truth right so if we can cultivate a
greater awareness around that then I
think we can be more empathetic more can
and perhaps more able to sense that
person who is in pain and and and needs
that help but how do we how do we how do
we overcome the massive forces of our
culture that want to keep us in that
space of mimimi and what am I gonna get
etc you know we feed our self we breathe
our self and these are the functions
that we have made important we have made
it important that I have my air that I
have my food that I have my house that I
have my car that I have my life that I
have my job and all of these problems
and my problems and all of these my
orientations have become what we educate
the head brain to achieve the answers to
but in fact when you sit in a
consciousness that is expanded when you
sit in a consciousness that has an
awareness of what you were just talking
about that we are in fact one being on
this planet the spaceship sailing
through the Stars you break that down
what we are is we are an electromagnetic
event you're an electromagnetic event
I'm an electromagnetic event and what
you have done is you have gathered the
density of body around your electro
magnetics I have gathered the density of
body around my electro magnetics what we
have gathered that density from is the
ocean of potential matter in which we
live so we are all bringing our body
from the same ocean of potential matter
and in that we are all one it's almost
as if there's this fluid that then
becomes a gel that then becomes ice and
it gets more and more solid as it
becomes rich as it becomes guru Singh
and so we are sharing matter and we are
looking out from the
of our conscious awareness in this
vehicle that appears to be me and
appears to be you but in fact it's we
and that were just two perspectives I
looked at a joke the other day a cartoon
and it was a big nine to one side and a
big 6 to the other side and it the title
under the cartoon was matter of
perspective and that's what when you say
mine right and you're referring to yours
if I was in your perspective if I put
myself in your shoes
it would serve me and vice versa and so
here we are were these electromagnetic
beings that have consolidated the matter
around our center core but that matter
that we have consolidated is mutual and
so your health is going to improve my
health your well-being improves my
well-being this is the awareness that we
have to teach kids from the age of three
four five and so that throughout their
lives they're working for each other and
with each other not competing at each
other right that was the subject of one
of your other daily prayers right it was
like cooperation cooperation for
competition mm-hmm well I understand
that there can be friendly competition
just to make you better right at what
you do but that's you know the most
unfriendly of all competitions is war
mm-hmm you know but every other
competition could just make you better
at what you do make your body better
make your mind better make your emotions
better well I mean sports is a vehicle
for teaching cooperation and teamwork
through competition so they're not
necessarily you know mutually exclusive
and correct in a binary way correct and
the the key here is that we are all one
and you know philosophically speaking
it's a nice phrase oh yeah we're all one
you know but if you break it down to
where it's actual science we are all one
we are I mean think of it in terms of
the
the cells came together right the the
one-celled animals came together in the
first multi-celled animals were called
colonies they all ate for their cell
they all [ __ ] for their self they all
lived and died for their cell and then
pretty soon what they did was they
started forming specialties and so some
became the the eaters some became the
the blood circulators some became the
respirators and that became a
multi-celled animal well right now we're
at a place where we're so numerous as
single individuals that we're going to
have to start working with and for each
other otherwise we can't continue to be
at each other but in certain respects we
are as human beings almost like the red
blood cells of these larger organisms
that we call cities societies yeah if
you if you're flying on an airplane and
you look down on Los Angeles it's like a
giant virus on the planet that's being
fueled you know and feet and fed by
human beings running around moving
things around for isn't it crazy to see
that say it's like you're going on
landing in that and we are we are
innovating our replacement through
through technology you know the advent
of artificial intelligence is starting
to is starting to you know come online
here and that presents a very
interesting conundrum for the human
condition so do you think we are
literally you know creating the next
evolution of the human beings that
perhaps will render us irrelevant and
maybe maybe that's a good thing I don't
know I mean but but this is happening
did you see where Saudi Arabia just
granted citizenship to the robot yeah I
did and these robots are basically
domestic servants they're the ones that
will take care of your house but they
have a vote and they have they have that
citizenship that autonomy as a citizen
of the country yeah I mean that's an
interest I mean it that's a bit of a
stunt especially in a part of the
that still has a lot of challenges with
human rights inequality and all of that
but you know even beyond that just the
idea that there that we are creating
sentience in a way that we don't
consider life because it's not based on
organ systems as we understand it but
perhaps is just a new form of life that
we have never conceptualized before like
the tadpole turning into the frog do you
know that that particular yes and out of
intense request which is the nature of
crisis crisis is an intense request for
some kind of change so yes in some of
those countries where they are quite
backward in their relationship between
the gender right between men and women
quite backward in their relationship to
sexual orientation quite backward in
their relationship to who does the heavy
lifting in the society wouldn't it be
wouldn't it stand a reason that they
might have the most extreme anomaly that
would take place like granting
citizenship to something that doesn't
have an actual beating heart and that
that what happened all those billion
years ago when the single-celled
creature started to team up with another
one and then all the single-celled
creatures of consciousness around it
went hey that's not real that's just
that's just you know two people two
things teaming up and but it kept
progressing and it kept progressing you
know the doctors now are saying okay
well you have an artificial lung or you
have an artificial this or you have a
kidney transplant so who are you are
that you the if you've had all your
organs transplanted from somebody else
who are you are you the transplant or or
you're the transplant II and who is
existing in and what is consciousness
and so what we have to now realize is
that okay there may be intelligence in
an artificial way is there consciousness
and that's what we have to realize is
that an intelligent being may not be a
conscious being and an unconscious being
may not have the empathy so we could be
creating intelligence that has the
ability to function in a an outstanding
way I mean they're there they've created
soldiers that can't be destroyed you
know like the the Terminator kind of
thing but if it doesn't have
consciousness if it doesn't have empathy
if it doesn't have compassion if it done
that any of these things stopping its
activities
what will we end up with and that's what
happened by the way to those cultures
throughout the stellar systems that have
destroyed their planets as a thought
experiment though similar to the one of
you know the old one about the boat if
you replace a plank by plank at what
point is it still your boat or is it a
different boat similarly if you take a I
and it continues to iterate and it
continues to develop and it becomes
better and better and better as a
predictor of human behavior and it
becomes so masterful at basically being
able to outwit outsmart out answer any
human being and mimic empathy and
happiness and sadness and depression
that it becomes so indistinguishable
from a human being
at what point if it continues to iterate
and iterate can we say that on some
level it does have consciousness and how
does that make you think about what
consciousness is and is not
that was a heavy one it reminded me of
MA
it reminded me of Monty Python yeah guy
comes ashore sticks a stick in the
ground with a piece of cloth waving on
it he says I hereby claim this land as
far as it travels for the Emperor the
low voice comes out of the bushes yeah
but what about us we've been here for
ten thousand years and he kind of looks
around dumbfound then he said yes but do
you have a flag right so what is
consciousness right what is that and can
that can that creature reproduce itself
or does it have to be produced
can it rebuild itself let's let's
presume that it can and that it becomes
so adept at it that it becomes
self-improving and when you apply
Moore's law to that it continues to
replicate and improve and produce that
rate so quick that before a blink of an
eye it's you know taking all the times
better than it was ten minutes ago and
there are planets throughout space
because this is not just a single
universe I think we spoke about that
before but it's just divots and a mega
verse and every universe thinks it's the
only one because they can't see anywhere
beyond itself but there are ancient
ancient ancient universes that have
already gone through what you just
described and it will be interesting to
travel in our conscious awareness to
those places to get the answer to your
question because there is that going on
because if it can be thought of here
it's been thought of in many places you
know I always look at this place that
you know they call it infinity right and
it's got to be infinite because if it's
not it's got to stop someplace and if it
stops someplace then there's got to be
something on the other side of the stop
and so it just has to keep stopping and
starting and keep going and stopping and
starting and keep going so it's infinite
no matter how you break
get down in someplace in this infinite
event what you just described is taking
place full force and the only way to
know the answer to your question
specifically is to go visit those places
and the only way to visit those places
currently is to visit them in your
meditative consciousness in a deep deep
deep way then it would take some effort
but I'm sure that we could come up with
the answer to that yeah you haven't
visited there yet not that specific one
you saw the expression on my face I
loved where you were going with that I
just that was fascinating because you
know who's ever who's ever I mean
obviously scientists are thinking along
those lines and and you've probably had
conversations with some of those people
that are extending themselves in that
direction it's it's real it's very real
it's converse it's a conversation we
need to be having because as much as our
you know human condition is to you know
biologically reproduce it's become just
as much about continuing to
technologically innovate right and no
matter how many stopgaps or you know
conversations we have about is this the
right thing to do or not or not to do
it's happening like it's just we can't
stop it whether it's gene sequencing and
what's going on with CRISPR and whose
craziness like hmm it's gonna get really
weird pretty soon I mean it's already
getting weird but like when my little
girls are you know 40 and 50 years old I
can't even begin to fathom what the
world is gonna look like it right still
we're talking the iPhone 10 years old
and now you've just multiplied that
times four or five and the advances that
will take place and by the way when
we're talking about what you were just
saying in the AI and and the betterment
and the self betterment and the in the
mimicry of compassion and empathy and
all of those things we're not just
talking about something being made out
of non organic matter we could be we
could be reproducing these things at a
biomatter and
we could be reproducing these things out
of waste matter and and this this could
then become a full-fledged biological
entity that's able to reproduce itself
kind of germ-free mm-hmm I don't even
know if it matters whether it's
biological or non-organic inorganic I
think we have to expand our thinking
about what we what we contemplate as
life and in organics could sure
eliminate the problem with virus and
bacteria yeah why it's perhaps a more
perfect system we shall see it right but
here's this is a doorway okay
stay - there's no mushrooms involved
around here right we just filled with
frogs but shifting gears a little bit I
wanted to talk a little bit about about
boundaries like as somebody who you know
we talked earlier a little bit about
shouldering the responsibility to carry
you know positive frequency and be an
agent of positive change through empathy
and connection and things like that but
there there also is it's also important
to have discernment about this just
because you're it's not like oh I'm all
loved and it's a free-for-all and you
can come invade my space and you know I
know that this has come up for you in a
personal way recently you had to like
eject somebody from in front of your
classroom or who was somebody who was
not behaving appropriately so I think
boundaries are important and I wanted to
kind of explore that a little bit with
you in terms of how you comport yourself
as as somebody who wants to be of
service but also is not somebody who is
there to be taken advantage of I look at
it as the sage warrior you know you're
the sage first and when necessary you're
the warrior that non-violence is
actually a term that means
non-aggression and that you're not
looking
to be aggressive but you're also not
looking to be overrun because it's
important for us too we like the whole
thing with with sexual predators that is
taking place and exposed in the world
today I said to the class the other day
I said ok everybody has to make a
promise raise your right hand I had
everybody raise their right hand and
then I will learn to really Swift moves
that can deck somebody instantly hmm in
other words if somebody is a predator
and they're approaching you you need to
be able to take a very swift action to
put them into a place where they're not
going to be a problem because we are not
here to be taken advantage of we are
here to be an advantage for everyone and
so we have to learn we have to learn how
to have that ability to take someone's
aggression down in an instant yes we
also have to learn the art of of
eminence of of supreme eminence of being
able to dominate a space to such a
degree like the Buddha that if you came
within you know a hundred feet of the
Buddha you had nothing but peaceful
thoughts but what if you have a rifle
that is capable of traveling far more
than a hundred feet in today's world you
know you could shoot a person from a
great distance from 3,000 feet or
something like that
what we have to do is we have to have
multi levels to our being one know that
if there's anything in the visual area
that has harm for you that has thoughts
of harm for you this is an awareness
like I was saying about the be finding
the flower this is the reverse of going
out and finding that person who is out
of harmony this is to actually know that
there's someone in your air is a highly
intuitive power and you've got to be
able to have that power secondly you've
got to be able to control the
the the frequencies within the clothes
rank within you know a few hundred feet
so that nobody can have that violent
attitude or that that obnoxious attitude
or that aggressive attitude of that
predators attitude within a few hundred
feet and then if both of those things
have failed and there's somebody right
in your face you have to be able to take
care of business and that's why the sage
Warrior is the is the answer name we're
not going to get there overnight we have
to get there you know it's it's years
and years and years of practice but this
is exactly what we have to know and that
for example let's talk about the sexual
predators that are so much in the news
these days they're victims of their own
inadequacy they're victims of what we've
been talking about their disconnection
what everybody longs for is their source
code we're all programmed to long for
our source code and the source code is
the womb from where we came and the
breast from where we were first nurtured
and so this whole obsession with the
womb with the vagina with the breast is
all about our sourcing we want to get
back to that place where we were either
completely held and safe or we were
completely nurtured and safe and the
only thing that's going to change that
or alter that no matter how
sophisticated we become is if we raise
our conscious awareness so that we know
that we've been there done that and
don't need that anymore and we are here
to provide that sanctuary for others so
we don't invade somebody else's space we
don't require sexual favors to kind of
satisfy that need of ours to go there
this is an again an educational this is
a bio physical education whereby we are
nurtured to come up from that very basic
I mean sexual predators are just babies
looking for the nipple sexual predators
are just babies
looking for the womb and the reality is
that we need to educate everybody so
that they can understand that's what's
happening and until we've educated
everyone so that that isn't happening
either through AI or whatever it's going
to be we need to be able to take care of
ourselves we need to be able to set up
boundaries we need to be able to not be
taken advantage of because this is I
mean we're getting crowded right as we
said seven and a half billion people I
mean la I don't know when you came to LA
but it was in the mid-60s when I first
came down here this place is crazy
bigger than it ever was you know used to
have some distance where you had some
land now there's nothing and everybody
is in their you know armored vehicle you
know driving around and as we get more
and more crowded we have to set up more
and more boundaries that are boundaries
of understanding rather than just
boundaries of walls and and in lines of
demarcation yeah we set up the wrong
boundaries yeah you know and the the the
sexual predator thing is super
interesting in in the sense that it's
coming up now it's not you know the
behavior is has been there yeah it's not
that suddenly there's a rise in the
behavior it's it's a rise in awareness
around the behavior and the outing you
know it's like it's like the the the
pimple has finally been popped right and
when you have you know Ronan Farrow
writes these articles in The New Yorker
and this all comes out and it creates
this cascading effect that is amplified
by social media and the me to campaign
and suddenly all these women finally
feel safe to relate their their stories
safety in numbers
which yeah which then you know sort of
amplifies the you know the waterfall of
of this narrative you know becoming
outed and and why do you think that's
happening now like it the juxtaposition
of that against the mass shooting thing
is
very interesting to me like the timing
of it like why is this happening now
exposure what you just said is true the
amount of ways in which something can be
exposed the amount of ways in which
people can connect are doing two things
they are allowing people to connect more
deeply more closely more prevalently but
they're also causing people to feel
disconnected to a greater degree so all
of the women on the me to campaign our
feeling connected they're feeling a
kindred spirit but as that kindred
spirit Rises the ones that have no means
of connecting at all are feeling more
and more estranged so the ones that are
feeling more estranged become more
violent the ones that are feeling more
connected become more powerful and less
vulnerable to the predator the sexual
predator and so these two things are
happening simultaneously because of a
third element and that third element is
that ability of information to travel
instantaneously across the world and now
I mean let's face it back in the
centuries sexual predators were called
successful people you know they weren't
even considered to be inappropriate
you've just dominated you've you've
you've conquered you've done whatever
you've done in today's world that well
that law has all changed I mean you even
heard from one of the Predators own
mouths saying well you know I was just
raised in the 60s when all this behavior
seemed to be okay well you know sorry
for the you know lack of education but
even then that behavior of unwillingness
you know forcing yourself against
unwillingness wasn't okay that was not
okay and the misinterpretation of
willingness and unwillingness is you
know is another factor too because you
know the unwillingness and yet the the
temptation of furthering a career these
are all of these really
and and gross distractions that are
being exposed in today's world by media
by social media yeah it goes back to two
tribes as well and you're talking about
you know the empowerment that this
community of women are people who have
been victims of this you know are
feeling and they're they can Co here and
create this tribe that's oriented not
geographically but around an idea mm-hmm
and the cohesion of that tribe is
amplified and quickened in the presence
of of an enemy that everyone can kind of
you know counterpoint against right the
enemy being the predator mm-hmm when the
enemy goes away the cohesion of the
tribe becomes lessened I think right so
it brings up this issue of the necessity
of of the other right to cohere the
group and so I'm wondering is it
possible to to create these tribes
without a necessity of of that of that
enemy and I think what I'm getting at
really you're really you're really on to
something I like what I'm getting at in
a broader sense is you know I think it
applies to the way that I kind of think
about our political climate right now
and as somebody who I'm on social media
you know my career is kind of you know
plays itself out there and I go on
Twitter and it's just it's the tribes of
you know the Democrats and the
Republicans and and how they're the this
battle the battle lines that are being
drawn and those boundaries are dictated
by you know the parameters of of policy
and perspective that these two groups
have right so they cohere in opposition
to each other and it goes back again
also to kind of take it in step in
further to you know how do we as
conscious beings who are trying to raise
the vibration approach these sorts of
issues whether it's the me to campaign
and the sexual predator issue or our
political climate and do it in a way
that is of a higher vibration
than just casting aspersions and and you
know shooting bows and arrows across the
bow one of the things that human beings
are moving toward is a social crisis you
know we've had physical crises before
and we're now entering the world of
social crisis because we have so many
connections across societies before it
was a village here and a village here
and a village here and what was going on
in the village could be either a crisis
or a benevolent circumstance but now
with this cross-pollination of people
throughout the world the boundaries in
political nature are completely
dissolving there's this thing called
what are they called net countries the
the fact that Facebook is a country that
Google is a country and that they have
no normal physical boundaries but people
are functioning in them across these
boundaries human beings have a destiny
to come together ultimately so and in
order to get together to come together
we have to dissolve our differences what
we're looking at now is you know in that
Newton's third law of motion again for
every action is a reaction for every
dilemma there is an accompanying
solution and it's right there but
because our brain is fixated on danger
from our survival you know decades and
centuries and millennia we are focused
on the danger we're focused on the
difference we're focused on how can I
keep myself safe from what you might do
right there with that there is just as
much similarity there is just as much
calm there's just as much peace so if
those of us that are focused in these
ways that are more inclined towards the
peaceful nature the coalition nature we
can shift the dynamic so that it's not a
mutual enemy
that gathers us together but it's a
mutual aspiration as opposed to a
desperation that gathers us together and
that is sustainable that mutual
aspiration is like everybody training
for the race right I immediately am
thinking of like a sports analogy yes
yes and that's why these things are so
important that's why I follow your
career is because I love what you get
out of it
I love how you get it out of it I love
the way in which it all takes place
because that is us looking at our
similarities what does he do that I can
do hmm what is what is he achieving that
I can achieve in that same way rather
than our differences which is oh heas
achieve it means I can't I haven't
achieved it or I'm comparing myself and
I become jealous now jealousy can be a
positive because I can become jealous of
what you've achieved and then strive to
achieve it myself and so I turn
everything into that positive and what
will be happening in the future if we
have something to say about it is that
we will be able to sustain those tribes
that were created out of mutual enemy by
introducing a mutual similarity okay now
that we've done the me too I'm just
saying as if I'm a you know a sexually
assaulted person man or woman doesn't
matter and and I'm a me-too participant
and so as the as the inertia of that
campaign begins to die down let's
maintain our connection because that
connection is powerful and let's
introduce something into that connection
and this is something that people like
you and I can do in our work is that we
can come up with the ideas of what to
introduce into it that becomes the next
meal it becomes the next meal that
gathers the me to campaign around a
table to be able to consume that okay so
we've accomplished this and we've
exposed sexual predators
now we're doing this and that and now
let's use this same coalition of forces
in a cooperation to achieve something
else and this is what we're going to use
to do it and and all of a sudden we
start replacing stimulus of negative
right then a the the stimulus of a
mutual enemy with the stimulus of a
mutual aspiration I like that I'm trying
to think of a practical example of that
other than sports mmm well immediately I
think back to our the first part of our
conversation which is education what
about what about all the women in the
me2 and all the men in the me to would
sort of combine you know almost like
group funding right what is it called
crowdfunding I love that I love the new
phrasing don't you the the way there so
what if everybody was decided to
crowdfund
educational emphasis on training
children from the age of you know early
education whenever that is in not being
available if there's a predator present
and there's no meal available for the
predator what is the predator gonna do a
predator leaves or the predator has to
dissolve its nature it's like the old
saying in the 60s what if they threw a
war and no one showed up right there
would be no war I always thought when
you know 200,000 Americans invaded Iraq
there was in the early stages there was
25 million Iraqis what if they all just
decided that hey let's all get together
on Sunday and surround the Green Zone
and just surround it right and just
surround it with love not with weapons
and we'll put the ones in the very front
who are going to get killed
the ones who you know are willing to die
for their cause and then the women and
children are you know when the way back
but you could have just cut it off you
truly are a sixty a child of the sixties
thinking outside that box yeah but I but
I'm a child of the 60s that remembers
the 60s because I wasn't it I wasn't a
druggie huh no but I mean you were we we
talked about this the last time on the
podcast I mean you were very much of
that oh yeah that time oh yeah and it's
coming back because what huge is well
that's what I was gonna ask you like
what is that when you kind of take the
temperature of the culture like what is
the difference between what that felt
like at that time at like you know peak
sixties versus the kind of activism that
that you're seeing now you got to watch
an HBO special that's taking place in
two parts right now it's called Rolling
Stone stories from the edge and it's
about Rolling Stone magazine and how it
got started and everything that
influenced it right and what it says in
that is what really influenced the 60s
was group consciousness was the fact
that people realized that together they
could achieve anything together they
could bring down the bad together they
could lift up the good and that's what's
happening here with with social media
with the me to campaign the me to make
somebody that's sitting in some place
maybe they were in Hollywood or in New
York striving to be in the industry and
they got raped or they got assaulted in
some way and it just freaked them out
and they left the industry and now
they're sitting in some small town in
some state somewhere and all of a sudden
this me two thing comes on and it's in
social media so it comes on their phone
and they realize wow me too and they're
now connected with thousands of other
people and they have been feeling
completely lost for a couple of decades
because their entire dreams and
aspirations got cut short by some
predator right I just bleep myself yeah
you believed yourself show up on the
video and you probably heard a little
bit in the in the audio track but yeah
because of some you know dumb predator
all of a sudden their career is
shattered and all of a sudden
it's reignited in some way where they're
feeling a part of a group that was what
went on in the 60s and it was a much
different setting because we didn't have
any of the media support that is there
today but group consciousness is really
really important and it's what's going
to save humanity if we get it going fast
enough
well crisis provokes that mmm you know I
think that the heightened sort of you
know situation that we find ourselves in
has motivated people to be more aware
and active in a way that we haven't seen
people are you know the the marshaling
of activism and you know everything from
people who are physically protesting in
the streets to you know what you're
seeing online is unprecedented in in my
lifetime yeah and look at what happened
in Houston in Florida and in Puerto Rico
where you know people just you know
crowdfunded and and flew down there and
when Haiti got hit by the earthquake
you know people went down there to help
I mean the ability to respond to crisis
is human nature and the ability to have
compassion in crisis is human nature
I remember you do too and right after
9/11 you know the world was saying we
are all Americans and it was an
interesting floaty kind of sensation for
a few weeks until that died down and
other things started to occur it's
interesting how crisis is the one thing
that allows people to transcend what we
were talking about earlier that sense of
separation and that you know zero-sum
mentality to be able to understand the
wholeness and the oneness of all of us
where status suddenly doesn't mean
anything it's what you're actually doing
you know the guy who shows up and you
know wherever the hurricane was to you
know pull people out of their homes and
we see these heroes and we we can
celebrate the human spirit in the midst
of these tragedies that unite us yeah I
loved it and so I wish we could you know
bottle that and find a way to you know
maintain that outside the
you know the temporal boundaries of a
crisis well I think one of the things it
would be good is that people like dr.
Bush that you spoke about that was very
much into measuring the results of
certain things in the endocrine system
you know we could measure the the
technologies that take place within the
psycho emotional and somatic bodies of
what happens in a crisis and we're you
know a millionaire takes his yacht and
literally he he drives it down the
street that's now flooded in ten feet of
water to save people out of his heart of
their homes so he's like the common man
now even though he's got a you know a
beautiful very very expensive yacht okay
crisis causes that to happen what other
kinds of circumstances we should do
studies and find out what other kinds of
circumstances are going to produce the
same biochemical consequence so that we
can then okay well let's produce some of
those let's create some of those
opportunities rather and have
opportunity produce the collective
consciousness rather than just crisis
because we have that ability we have the
ability to measure today
I think the thread that that that runs
through it is is connectivity when a
crisis happens people are able to let go
of their [ __ ] and and connect for a
greater good and and they come together
unified over a central you know
heightened scenario to collectively
overcome it right and they they have
done studies I mean they have we know
that depression rates and suicide rates
went down in New York City in the
aftermath of 9/11 hmm and it makes you
because you know there was a sense of
community and and connectivity that
obviously took took place that that you
know you just fed me with a new piece of
data well I mean I think it's I love
that I'm sure there's a lot more on that
but I think it you know when I think
about that it makes me think that we
need to we need to read we need to
rethink
how we conceptualize happiness
altogether you know I had I had I've had
Dan Buettner on my podcast a couple
times he just came on and talked about
happiness and studied all the cultures
that are the most happy and the sort of
thematic you know things that these
cultures share and it's not about the
things that we prioritize in our culture
it is about that connectivity it's about
you know how we're honoring our elders
it's about you know how it's about you
know the small simple things that we
tend to overlook is frivolous well diet
is important because if we were to
clarify our diets we would be a lot more
susceptible to those endocrine
chemistry's that would make us joyful
and for example you were talking sports
and how sports is a great unifier you
know in the World Cup in the women's
world cup of soccer
you know the American team for a couple
of series over the last couple of
decades has come out on top and it has
really turned the entire country into a
soccer fan which is something unusual
because number one women's sports have
never been as a big a draw as men's
sports and soccer has never been as big
a draws football baseball and basketball
in America and so achievement is another
mechanism by which we can unify not just
crisis but so we have crisis we have
achievement we have diet we have all of
these things and if we were to create a
program a campaign that is revolving
around connection achievement
compassionate competition avoid
avoidance of crisis and all of these
things and know that we're going to get
heavy pushback from the capital side
which is going to want to have you know
something else take place that will
create crisis or what have you and not
spend our energies reacting to the
capital side of things that are going to
try to create division but stay focused
on our
game we might have a 20-year plan here
sounds good well given that we according
to you we only have 35 if you will be
good good shape right yeah and I
actually don't use the one execute I use
the word implement okay to me but to me
execute is like is like a killing verb
yeah I get that yeah I'll be more
mindful about yeah it's fun
well we got it let's see oh man we got
to shut this down in a little bit but I
thought like a good way to kind of end
this would be to ask you a question a
version of a question that I often ask
doctors medical doctors that I've had on
the show and one of the questions I
always ask them at the end is if you
found yourself transported to a parallel
universe and you were named to be the
Surgeon General what kind of changes
would you attempt to implement in our
culture so I thought a good question for
you would be if you woke up in a
parallel universe which I have dimension
which this is a daily experience for you
yeah I don't know maybe you're in a
different dimension I've rehearsed this
answer many times you were named to be
the the guru general the spiritual
master general of you know Western
society at large maybe not just the
United States but you know kind of
culture as we live it what would you
like to what what would be the changes
that you would try to implement well I
would look at a I would look at a twenty
thirty forty year plan starting from
children at the ages very young to three
four years old and I would look to
achieve measurable results in 15 20
years when the children are coming into
their adulthood rather than trying to
fix the adults that are already there I
would like them to be inspired by
watching the children that are growing
up in a new way and that way would be
one of educating the emotional body
through the gut brain and the heart
brain as strongly as we educate the
intelligent body through the head brain
and have have courses such as confidence
and courage and compassion and and all
of these self identity self valuation
instead of just having service of others
in a 12-step program when people have
reached the place of of desperate need
and trying to step themselves back into
equilibrium let's take the 12 steps and
install them actually in all of
education at a very early age they don't
have to they don't have to experience
addiction in order to go to the 12 steps
and Sophal actively taking the 12 steps
absolutely absolutely and and and find
all of the things that have worked
throughout those elements the 12-step
programs that the spirit based programs
the athletic programs the team building
programs and have those be as much of a
mandatory course not just an elective
but a mandatory course and then learn
them through what like that Russian
school that you were talking about
through group through group effort where
everybody is working on the same thing
and everybody is building towards a
common goal so what we end up with in 15
and 20 years is adults entering the
system that the idea of me my my me mine
is is quite foreign to them funny yeah
yeah but the idea of how to collectively
collaborate to solve a problem is second
name it's absolutely second nature have
a funny story quickly and that is that
you know we have a school in India and I
came out of our morning daily practice
which you know starts before the rise of
the Sun when we do yoga and meditation
and I start looking around for my
sandals which in India are called
chapels and I can't find my can't find
my chapels and a little kid comes
walking up to me says can I help you and
you know because there's like been 150
people in the room and there's just a
massive trouble I said yeah I can't find
my I can't find my sandals he says
doesn't matter just take any pair that
fits I said really he said that's what
everybody does he says you got Chapel he
said somebody just took you
yeah you got chapel because somebody
just took your shoes because they fit so
I did I took somebody else's shoes which
for the first ten steps felt really
weird because you know somebody else's
shoes have been on somebody else's foot
and we're all one we are all one so the
funny thing is about three or four days
later as I'm coming in I see my shoes
and they have a story to tell me because
they've been on three or four different
kids feet right and that's the group
conscious if if yours doesn't work have
mine and you literally get to walk a
mile on someone in someone else's shoes
yeah and I think that that that brings
this whole thing full circle to where
where we began and in terms of the
education system
look when when every person is walking
around with a supercomputer and they're
in their pocket that can answer any
question and every fact is available in
you know only as quickly as you can type
it or say it into this computer that has
to impact the way that we're educating
our kids because it's not about
memorizing facts any morals when they
can find that whenever they need to it
needs to be about how to think automatic
spellcheck we don't have smelling tests
anymore right I mean is it necessary and
are we talking enough about how we're
gonna modernize an update how we're
indoctrinating our kids to you know
inherit this planet from us that is in
survival mode and in desperate condition
so I like that expression how we're
indoctrinating rather than how we're
educating how we're indoctrinating our
kids to save a planet that's in survival
mode whoo mmm good one-liner it's a good
way to end it it is I should let you get
the last word though yeah I think I did
but yes then you just want up
we'll pick it up again you come on like
every month oh let's do it on the
podcast yeah I do I do a coaches corner
with my coach when we talk about like
support stuff but we could have like a
guru corner yeah and and we can have
courses like what we were talking I was
gonna hold this up actually so guru
Singh and I are talking about perhaps
doing a course together and we're
actually not talking about perhaps we're
talking about doing it yes and I cannot
Mir and I he greets me any hand he goes
here I'm just I have this I woke up this
morning and I had this idea so you can
see it on the video but uh it says
extreme awareness Elite Fitness the
mental and physical muscles of greatness
with guru Singh in which role that
sounds like a cool course it is I'd like
to take it I would too my so let's take
it together and let other people take it
with them what are we gonna tell people
I figure that part out work that well so
yeah I'm looking forward to figuring
this out with you I think it'd be really
fun it will be cool and monthlies I'm
I'm good with coaches gurus corner
surgeries corner all right well I'll put
some thought into that as well excellent
man all right my brother
ah this is really really a pleasure I
would tell you just from the first time
that we met you know two people that
live life on the top rather than on the
bottom is really important my father
always said and here's the last word
right yeah I stuck it in my father
always told me said if you never want to
run out of gas realize that it's just as
easy to keep the top half of the tank
full as it is the bottom half and so for
two people that keep the top half of our
tanks full I love working with you
feeling's mutual bless you alright bless
you peace peace and Satnam laughs
namaste hahaha mama stay Sadhna
plant-based that's right
you did it good job
[Music]